[Music]
now we haven't heard much in the way of
solutions from the government on the
fuel crisis but with tory conference
starting on sunday is that about to
change the conservatives go into their
annual meeting with a very comfortable
majority but after a difficult month
following on from the unveiling of the
national insurance tax hike to pay for
health and social care to discuss how it
will go i'm joined by our political
editor james forsyth and tory mp and
duncan smith
james anne thanks for joining me
james first tory party conference starts
on sunday but we're in the middle of
both a gas price and fuel crisis
is this a chance to reset the agenda
i think if you said this will be the
first
tory conference after the party wins an
80-seat majority you would have thought
that it would be a kind of champagne
fueled kind of victory bash but
obviously
a lot has happened uh since the tories
won that that victory in december 2019.
and i think there's obviously not only
the kind of short-term concerns prompted
by the petrol crisis and uh these rising
gas prices and what they mean for the
winter ahead but i also think there is
there is that there is a kind of bigger
nagging philosophical question bugging a
lot of tories right now which is kind of
you know what is the purpose of this
government this government was
essentially elected in 2019 to kind of
get brexit done and keep jeremy corbyn
out and it has done both of those things
now
uh you then obviously had the pandemic
which took up you know nearly all of the
government's bandwidth
and time
and so now the question is you know what
is the government's post pandemic agenda
and i think that is what they are going
to need to flesh out in manchester next
week
and no doubt the party will be looking
backward to the victories that it had
even before the covet crisis hit but
still these these are not ideal
circumstances to be heading into the
torres party conference
well we have to say first of all that uh
kovid
is like a war
in the sense that it's knocked the
agenda of the government such as it
existed back in the end of 2019
beginning of 2020 it's knocked it
punched a hole through it really
so recovering out of kovid a year and a
half in to a government uh means that
we're almost starting from scratch in a
sense so this conference is
the first public conference but it's
also almost really the first conference
because everything else has been covered
so the questions that we pose is what
kind of government are we going to be as
a conservative government and i think
the range of options lies clearly
you know sort of teddy heathian
government or a margaret thatcher style
government where you know it's a case of
low taxes and lower spending and greater
booming economy um private sector taking
over so the question really is where do
we lie on the spectrum of that and where
do those phrases uh build back better
and leveling up what do they actually
mean when you get to test them in the
arena of political decision so those are
the big questions that will be posed uh
there are a lot of funny and strange
answers that are already coming out in
the midst of that it's worth reminding
ourselves of mcmillan's what do i fear
most
events dear boys events
and the truth is we are facing also
within all of that
a set of events postcode a lot of them
coming out of kovid which will
uh almost like earthquakes uh have
seismic shocks that go through the
system you know one is the whole failure
on uh haulage drivers because they shut
down
uh every single testing center uh
stupidly during the course of covid
that's exacerbated an already existing
problem the uh
the mendacity and peculiar selfishness
of many of the holier companies who have
invested next to nothing in their
drivers for so long uh being
torn away by cheap labor from eastern
europe all of these were meant to be
brexit questions that were settled but
we find
actually brexit is still looming in the
mirror because these are still there and
they're causing us problems so
competence is critical how do we display
that we have to be free of this petrol
pump problem by the time we get to the
conference and then it's about policy
and direction and sending us off
believing that we have a purpose james
let's talk about the definitions of
these slogans because when you scroll
through the fringe guide for tory party
conference leveling up is undoubtedly
one of the most popular topics do you
think we're going to learn over the next
few days what the slogan actually means
i think the question of what is what
does leveling up mean now i think
everyone knows what it means in terms of
the long term
i think the challenges i honestly don't
genuinely i mean does it mean tax rises
which we've had does it mean um tax
breaks for you know people who are on
lower incomes uh what i have no idea to
be honest what the
long-term
victory is
long-term the aim is that every part of
a country
should be as prosperous as london and
the south east that is obviously the
kind of utopian kind of boris johnson
view of what leveling up means
i think that obviously the more
complicated question is how do you get
there and what are the stops along the
way now boris johnson is very
he wants a very broad definition of
leveling up he thinks the fact that it
encompasses lots of things is part of
its appeal
i actually think you need a much
tighter definition of leveling up
around boosting economic growth from the
regions and devolving power down if you
i think one of the things that you see
is this is still a very centralized
country and if you look at those bits of
uh those bits of england which are
uh
making you know doing well in terms of
inward investment and the like they are
often places that have a mayor someone
who can act a quran investment there
bring people together make sure things
work and i think those i think those are
should be the two
big levers that the government tries to
pull on leveling up you know which is
one of which is giving away power and
down to it down to a local level and i
think this is i mean the problem of
leveling up is at the moment is is it is
that it is in danger of becoming like
build back better it's just in danger of
becoming a slogan that the government
attaches to everything it does
rather than a policy agenda james what
do you think the prime minister wants to
get out of his party conference i think
if you um we've interviewed dominic rob
for the magazine this week uh and you
know he mentioned delivery probably more
times in that interview than any other
single word you look at the kind of
click every clip boris johnson does
right now it's about delivery i think he
wants to give this sense that the
government is you know is getting back
on with stuff postcoded and it and he's
doing what it said it would do i think
that is the i think that's what boris
johnson thinks is the most important
message for him to get out of that
conference
uh i think that the challenge for him
is
uh on
you know they often talk about social
care for example and the health and
social care level is an example of
delivery
it's not yet delivery it's a decision to
raise taxes to put more money into the
nhs and to in time find more money for
social care it's not actually delivering
that new system and i think you know i
think in one of the things that
ian said that kobe was like a war i
think one of the other things we forget
is just how much of this parliament
covert has already taken up this
government is operating on a very
compressed timetable if it wants to make
visible changes to people's lives by the
next election
and and this brings us back to a point
that you raised at the start of this
discussion which is that the tories have
this big question hovering over them
what kind of party do they want to be do
they want to be more interventionist
more big state do they want to go down
eventually a lower tax route what would
you like to see from the tory party and
what are you hoping to hear at
conference
well actually now on the positive side
what uh you know we've talked a lot
about the problems but the truth is
there are some big positives for this
government if they have the energy and
the courage to seize them we left the
european union one of the key reasons
why if not almost the most important
reason why is when we say take back
control
it's about what do we believe in
regulation what's the level of
regulation that should be set the
interference in people's lives i was
asked by the prime minister to do a
report called the tigger report and it's
about what can we do to deregulate and
change and we came forward with a
significant number over 100
recommendations but more importantly to
shift the concept of regulation not to a
an absolutely over intrusive process
that says you know if anything could go
wrong we have to measure that before it
happens and actually allow as they do in
common law iterative change now that
means basically the real underpinning of
this economy is about how you make the
uk economy light on its feet
very inventive all the innovation areas
from medical tech through to uh
fight financial technology all of these
things are all there for us to grab but
we have to be bold and this government
in the next year and this is pretty much
all it's got has got to shift mountains
in terms of regulation it's got to make
sure that we are a very attractive place
the most attractive place in europe to
invest money in because we're the place
where you can build these things we can
compete with california because we know
where we're going there's no reason why
you should be governed by companies in
california need to change the rules
around gdpr allow people to take greater
control there is a whole report and it's
good that david frost is now going to
drive that through government but it
requires government ministers not to be
bound down by civil servants and to make
those changes if we do that this will
open up the british economy after kovid
and it will make us a really powerful
force for innovation all these
technologies are in existence here at a
time when we have real issues over how
we trade with china and various others
the uk could be a real hub for all of
this i would drive that now that is what
i believe
leveling up is all about because it'll
bring business to areas around the uk
other than london that can actually
develop these technologies and be at the
heart of it that gives business
entrepreneurship and real rises in
salaries away from all those cheap
salaries that we thought we could pay
previously and now into serious
value-added work that we could do this
is the uk that voted to leave the
european union if we don't do that there
was no purpose in us leaving at all
leveling up is the government going to
deregulate
it has to be it has to be it's not just
i'm not talking about casualty
well david frost has now been tasked
with that and that's the one brilliant
thing that has happened i know that he's
really focused on this and a lot of
people don't understand what we mean by
deregulation it's not slash and burn
it's about resetting the whole nature of
how we look at regulation in the in the
way in which we deal for example with
common law it's about you know if we
don't know whether it's dangerous we
don't legislate for it we let ourselves
discover those things and only intervene
when it's necessary this is the whole
key to it and with that you know there
is huge areas in medical technology
which the uk is already to lead we could
be blowing that right out the water
the same with fintech and everything
else they're right on the cusp the uk
could be that nation that literally
competes with the best in the world but
it requires us to take advantage of
leaving the european union this is the
test are we serious are we brave are we
bold and will we do it because if we
meander around in the next year and a
half trying to figure out what we're
going to do in the short term it's not
going to work leveling up and building
back better are about getting the uk
the most flexible nation in europe and
also competing on that global state and
that requires us to shift the burden of
regulation and innovation so that we
bring businesses here to the uk
and what's the mood of the tory mps
going into party conference
well it's it's difficult you know
they're still upbeat you know we won a
big majority labor as we see in this
labour conference is still at each other
yes there's been some improvement in a
way uh in some of their rules but the
truth is labour still doesn't quite know
where it's going it still made a series
of hostages to fortune so the tories
coming into the conference will still
feel upbeat they still feel that you
know in boris they've got probably the
world's best political salesman and you
do need a good salesman at the helm but
we also need good strategy as well and
that's important but you know i think
they're still upbeat but they're they're
beginning to get concerned that we need
to see some pace on all of this and we
you know we're not the party that spends
its time rising tax raising taxes we've
got to be in the business of getting the
economy right and many of them said to
me what we need to do is treat the debt
like war debt from covid and get on to
really engineer this economy get lower
taxes get lower regulation and really
make this economy zing if we do that
we'll be able to pay back the debt at a
more accelerated pace but first let's
get the economy moving and not do things
like raising national insurance and for
things that will never happen i mean
honestly if anyone believes the health
service in three years time is going to
give back any money to social services
then i have to say they haven't been in
politics very long
james uh we are getting tax rises the
economy um well we don't know if it's
stagnated but the figures from august
were
extremely disappointing um
what what sense are you picking up from
tory mps is there this optimism that
that am points to or some of them
slightly more depressed
i think there is a desire for a greater
sense of what the tory party is for what
the government is for that point about
you know post-brexit postcovid what is
the government trying to do i actually
think if i was a tory mp the thing that
would alarm me most this week was andrew
bailey's speech on monday evening saying
that the recovery is already weakening
uh warning about the dangers of having
to put up interest rates because of
inflation but with the economy not being
strong enough or robust enough to take
that and here's warning that these
supply and labor shortages are are going
to get worse not better
and his warning that this autumn is
going to be hard yards i mean i think
this is but i think it is that economic
backdrop but that is that is the biggest
risk of a tourist and i think as ian was
saying one of his earlier answers you
know the government this autumn is going
to be difficult uh uh
in part because of some delayed shocks
from covid some brexit adjustments and i
think the government has to give a sense
that it is that it is in charge but it
knows what is doing that is not being
buffeted by events
james last question to you what should
spec tv watchers be looking out for at
toward tory party conference any
tensions any major moments that you
would be looking for
i i think the interesting question is is
i mean there is a a bubbling away under
the surface and it might come to the
surface given that this is the first in
person conference in in such a long time
is the question of you know what is the
point of the tory party um
has it become
uh
one um one senator said to me recently
we were elected as fatch rights we
govern as goalists you know has the tory
party now essentially become a goalless
party or you know is it going to go back
uh more to that that that kind of that
the thatcherite settlement uh so i think
watch that question and then i think
also
watch to see in this debate about the
post-brexit adjustment i mean you see
this
very interestingly you know dominic rob
in this interview for the spectator this
week is very explicit you know but
basically if you were to uh issue you
know a hundred thousand visas to lorry
drivers as kierstarmann suggesting you
know he says you know that wouldn't
solve this country's you know um being
hooked on cheap labor it would just be a
sticking past the solution i mean the
only solution he argues is to kind of
raise wages in in all of these jobs
where where firms struggle to find
enough british workers to fill the gaps
i think that the tension between that
thinking and the desire to make sure
that christmas is uninterrupted i think
that that is going to be something that
bubbles along
at this conference and also the whole
related to that the whole question of a
tory party's relationship with business
i think is going to become an
increasingly interesting question uh to
what extent you know
should the tory party be doing what kind
of business wants in terms of
immigration the like or to what it's
censored the government be saying to
business no no you're gonna have to pay
people more invest more in training i
think those three tensions are the
things that i'll be looking out for not
not i don't you'll see that much of it
on the conference uh platform but i
think on the conference fringe those and
in the bars those will be the big
questions being debated
[Music]
you